this this song
this one
i'm telling you
it you know i put it on i was like
first i was like okay my toes going
right and then the shoulders are moving
and i i challenge anybody who's
listening to this song to not want to
just get up and dance this one
congratulations on this
thank you so much
i really really appreciate that thank
you
yeah this has that thing of like it
sounds like now but also reminds me so
much of like
music that my family and i used to dance
to in the kitchen like stuff that my mom
would play and we got and it's fitting
that this is off of familia like is this
is this part of this like what you grow
up on as well this sound
totally i mean i i think that
there is like you know uh
an area of latin music that's very
celebratory and
makes you want to dance and you you know
put it in your airpods while you're
you know sweeping the floor and stuff
and you know i think that
i think that this was just me like
choosing joy
in this moment and that's what this song
is to me it's like choosing
joy and laughter and
silliness and and dancing in the middle
of a you know crazy time
yeah
you know i heard that you had
come up with the idea while you were in
your bedroom
and to me this is like like we just
talked about this is like a dancing
everywhere a song
so is it you sitting in your bedroom
going you know what's next or is it
something coming to you
and then you having to go to your
bedroom space like as a creative space
and get it out
no i mean actually
i i i didn't i uh
you know scott harris and i started
writing songs for
my album in my bedroom in miami but this
was
um when scott and i went to l.a um i
have a studio in my house
and uh we invited mike sabbath to come
over and the three of us
uh wrote this idea that day
yeah
so this is often familiar it's like a
hint of
some of the sound that we're gonna get
off of this album
yes and no i mean there's no other song
in the album that sounds like this
it's in the same world but you know
they're all really different
but it definitely is like you know
there's a lot of cuban
and mexican sounds on there
um
there's a couple songs in spanish
um
it's just different different stuff
all around
i think if i was going to choose a music
video that i would have loved to have
been a part of in the last two years
it is this one like it literally looks
like you guys are just partying the
whole time and as i understand it was a
family affair too who all was there with
you
on that shoot that's part of your family
my dad was there my sister was there my
mom was there my cousins were there
my sister's friends were there my
friends were there
ricky reed
who i made my album with and scott
harris mike sabbath
chechey
all collaborators that i made my my
album with
um were all there so
you know people who are drunk
and survive thanks
how does it change things when you've
got people that are that close to you
that you're able to to share and
celebrate that work with
i mean it just makes it like a hundred
times better like it's 100 times more
meaningful it's like you know ricky reed
my producer always told me it's like
it's different it's different winning
with your friends
you know
just it's different
yeah what was the drink of choice sunset
you said it was a vibe liberation mezcal
mezcal
beautiful of course and also valentino
was there with you
in the
in the video are you a big fan you love
drag race
yeah i mean i i
i love them um
and
like they were so amazing
on set uh
and so funny
cracking me up the whole time
seeing you surrounded by
family in this video is that how you
envision
your life years down the road do you
want to be
the matriarch of this of this big family
of people celebrating together partying
together dancing together
such a sweet question um
yeah i mean i definitely do that would
be like
the dream scenario is to have you know
not just like
kids and grandkids and stuff but just
like a ton of friends that you know
and and friendships that have grown over
the years i think that's definitely like
the dream to get to that
point where you just have
a whole table of people that
you love and love you yeah
uh i love that you had talked about it's
different when you're winning with those
people that you love that are close to
you but before you get to
those wins you know you got to build it
right and so when you're building a song
when you're putting the song together
who is it that is like sort of your
litmus test who do you go to when you go
like
close to you not just a collaborator but
like close to you that you go
you know i love this is gonna work like
what do you think
i mean i think that i kind of have
adopted a practice of just
kind of being my own
litmus test like just like
not because there's you know it's
because there's nothing really to test
like it's like
it's just if i like it or not you know i
kind of feel like
i used to do something before where i
would be like
asking everybody is this good is this
good is this good is this bad is this
good and
i just feel like then you just are not
you know it's very simple i feel like
with
with art it's like you either resonate
with it and like it or you don't i mean
obviously
i share
once like
i know how i feel about something i'll
share it you know with sean i'll share
with my manager
um
but i think the first person that has to
know how i feel about it is me
what was the point where you got to when
you realized that we were like maybe i
don't have to ask everybody maybe i can
trust my own intuition
this album
i just didn't show anybody anything
until i was like
okay
most things at least
um so i was like okay i really like this
and then when you did that when you made
that discovery like wait well the
decision i i want to say
what did you discover about yourself and
your own strength
with regards to being able to do this
like make those decisions yourself
without having to say to someone is this
good
you know i i think that that's something
that i feel like you know i remember
reading untamed by glennon doyle
which is this amazing book where she
talks about how you know she was like
going to get a divorce from her husband
and she found herself
on google being like should i divorce my
husband it's like
so much so much of the time it's like
we're like we ask everybody before
we can trust ourselves you know and i
feel like
that's been a really good practice in
all areas of my life like instead of
being like what do you think about this
what do you think about that what do you
think about this choice should i do this
should i do that it's like
before i start doing that i gotta just
like hear my own
gut
first
yeah you know as you know just makes me
more more confident more confident in
in life just being like you know what i
can
trust that i'll make the right decision
and if not then i'll learn from it and
it'll i'll be okay
as a figure that people look up to
i think that's an important message to
actually be able to get out there
because there are people that are going
to your
to your social
or they might look at you as an example
which is sort of a weird thing you
because you just said i'm i don't want
to look to anybody else to make
decisions for myself but then there are
people that come come to you and kind of
see how is camilla doing it
and i think that's very cool because
you get to influence people to follow
the way that you are let's say follow
what you're thinking but get them to
stand on their own two feet as well is
that really an important part of
the message that you want to get across
even with social media
yeah definitely i mean i feel like
the way that i live is like
so influenced by people around me and
the content that i watch and the books
that i read and the people that i follow
and you know
the more that that stuff is
sane and rational and positive
and empowering the better my life is and
the better thoughts i have so
if i can like be a part of that
you know part of the
solution and not the problem
then
that's great
going back to
the album and like the process of
getting these songs together and the
inspirations for this music
um
i kind of want to figure out from you
where do they come from is there a spot
that you go to like a physical place
where you go to that is sort of your
idea place or do you let them just come
to you at any given time like how do you
set aside that space and time to be
creative
i think the space is actually more
emotional for me i think it's a safe
space of collaborators
for me it was like you know me ricky and
and
and scott or like me scott and mike were
kind of the two groups um
and i think like ricky and scott ricky
reed and scott harris were really
almost like my therapist like just like
listening to everything i was saying and
they made me feel really safe to go into
the booth and just like
freestyle
and write and like talk about
how i feel and say weird things and you
know like ricky would say to me like
talk that like be vulnerable
tell the truth even if it's
uncomfortable
so for me that space is really emotional
it's just like
a safe space it's like literally like
therapy it's like trusting your
therapist
yeah there's obviously an evolution in
the process
that we've just talked about do you find
that there's an evolution too in
even your own sound the way that you use
your voice
yeah i mean i think that
for
most of the songs i was kind of it would
start by me kind of like
freestyling uh lyrics and melodies in
the booth so
i think it just came from a place
inside me like it wasn't
i wasn't singing you know
another person's
you know words or melodies or whatever
like it was just like literally
the purest form of like stream of
consciousness
you know so
you'll probably hear a difference in my
voice for sure
is it fair to say that
some of that comes with uh you know
knowing yourself but also maturity as
well
definitely yeah i think it comes from
maturity it comes from
you know
uh
experiencing
you know another a different therapist
like my therapist has helped me a lot i
feel like throughout this album process
and um
slowing down like really taking care of
my mental health getting to know myself
more
it's a lot of different things you know
but i definitely feel like it's like
a lot of growth has happened
it was last time that you said don't go
yet to somebody
that's such a good question
um
sean probably today
or he's like i have to go work out and
i'm like no
don't go yet
stay stay here with me
yeah
and a lot of people are also excited uh
to see you in cinderella
and we love that billy porter because is
there with you what was it like working
with billy
billy is amazing i mean he
at first i was so intimidated when he
walked
on set because i feel like he's just so
talented and
has this like incredible
confidence and authenticity
um
and you know i was like really nervous
and i told him that and like
he just gave me really good advice about
being nervous and using it and
was really vulnerable with me about his
feelings and his life and
i feel like by the end of it we like
really
connected like i can't wait to hang out
with him again and see him again
it sounds
like billy played the real role of your
fairy godmother like well that's what he
said to me too
yeah by the end of it he was like i'm
you're real fabulous godmother now i was
like great
so
says better than
even being in the movie
what a blessing to have what a blessing
camilla thank you so much for this time
congratulations again and um this song
is going to be non-stop the song is
going to be nonstop now
you know thank you so much
you're awesome i super enjoyed the
interview you have a great energy oh
thanks you too pleasure talking with you
you